if you want to know about all of the
time travel mistakes and inconsistencies
in happy deathday to you then stick
around to the end of this video this
video is sponsored by shudder and their
new series of discovery of witches this
show has got witches vampires demons and
haunted houses and these creatures are
secretly living alongside man hidden in
plain sight
it's based on the best-selling All Souls
trilogy and it's got Teresa Palmer from
hacksaw Ridge and Matthew Goode from
Downton Abbey and the crown season 1 is
out now exclusively on shudder and
Sundance now and there are already two
more seasons on the way so check out the
description for a free 30-day trial
happy deathday to you opens with ryan
waking up in his car filled with hot
pocket rappers and walking down the
street to go back to the dorm on the
morning of tuesday than 19 this is just
a few minutes before the final scene of
the first movie where ryan does make a
reference to having asleep in his car
she's back oh I'm not sleeping with my
car good it smells like hot pockets and
feet when ryan gets into the dorm
building he crosses through a student
blowing a horn at one of the dorm rooms
this is the first time we're seeing
something that's only heard in the first
movie every time tree wakes up after the
loop resets to Monday the 18th this can
be heard in the distance okay what is
this in early Smosh video
[Music]
so after getting kicked out of his room
Ryan goes to the Science Building to
check on his invention the sisyas
quantum cooling reactor nicknamed the
[ __ ] for shorts here we learned the
machine has been eating up a ton of
power to operate which is the reason for
all the power outages in the first movie
our tuition dollars at work I don't know
why this machine would affect the power
and other buildings because that's not
really how electricity works but maybe
it has more to do with this machine's
interdimensional effects and less to do
with power consumption there are a
couple of funds set deck things I
noticed in the lab like a little
figurine of Nikola Tesla the guy who
basically invented the alternating
current electricity system that we use
today
there are also some magazines on the
table called zombie power magazine the
director of the happy deathday films
Christopher Landon also made a movie
called Scouts guide to the zombie
apocalypse after the school's Dean tells
Ryan that they'll have to confiscate the
machine he wanders around the Science
Building trying to find his fellow nerds
where he's killed by a masked Baby Face
killer causing his day to reset to the
beginning of Tuesday the 19th so he
wakes up in his car where we can see his
license plate reads mecco which might
have something to do with his mechanical
engineering skills ryan gets back to the
dorm room and explains what just
happened he tells tree and Carter that
he feels like he's going through deja vu
which is exactly what tree said when she
first experienced the time loop in the
first film right now oh I have it all
the time it's supposed to mean like
someone's thinking about you while
they're masturbating I have at least
five times a day do you want to tell her
or should I so they end up going after
this new killer with a baseball bat
I'm sure the actress Jessica Roth who
plays tree appreciated having the bat in
her hands this time
I know that all the Ducks were really
good unfortunately for her the killer
gets away this time so they head to the
place that Carter believes they'll be
safest from the baby mass killer the
basketball game where literally
everybody has a baby mask the fans of
this team got really clever with their
signs nicknaming the stadium the cradle
and coming up with slogans such as
babies gonna deliver which is funny
because it's usually the doctor who
delivers the baby but at the end of the
movie it's the babies delivering the big
blow to the doctor doctor boiler tree
also runs into Tim who she gives a
thumbs up when she notices him sitting
next to this guy in the stands it's a
reference to her accidental discovery
that Tim is gay when trying to
investigate who her killer is in the
first movie but after the basketball
game was out baby face comes after Ryan
with a knife and ends up chasing him
into the storage area of the bay field
University merch store where tree knocks
out the killer with a basketball trophy
had a little practice well who is it the
one way to find out it's old man
Witherspoon from the graveyard and he
would have gotten away oh no never mind
it's just another Ryan so they go back
to the lab again to try to send a Doppel
Ryan back to his own dimension
but inadvertently end up sending tree to
another dimension which I'll be calling
dimension B only in this dimension she's
still stuck in Monday the 18th and she's
understandably furious at Ryan for
sending her back this causes Carter to
ask them if they know each other
Ryan says no because this version of
Ryan has never met tree and tree says
yes because she doesn't realize this is
actually dimension Bo Ryan this is an
inverse of something that happened at
the sorority launch in happy deathday
wait you two know each other no we had a
class together last year as the day goes
on and she notices that this dimension
has many differences from her dimension
Carter and Laurie know each other and by
the way Laurie is not evil now Danielle
and Carter are dating because Danielle's
seemingly nice in this dimension for
example she recommends doing the special
needs art fair charity and she's
actually excited about it
dimension B whereas in dimension a and
we still need to pick this year's
charity I can say right now there's no
way we're doing the special needs heart
fair again there are still fundamental
similarities between the two dimensions
though the power goes out at the same
time Laurie still covers a double shift
for Jen at the hospital during a double
for Jana chest flip and tree still has a
birthday lunch with her father at the
same time only in this dimension her
mother is still alive as well and she
also attends the birthday cake that her
dad brings out it looks identical to the
cake that we see on the video and trees
phone when she's looking back at her
memories of the shared birthday with her
mom in the first one tree explains the
situation to the Nerds and Carter
compares it to the events of Back to the
Future - I guess tree really makes an
effort to stay away from movies because
just like at the end of happy deathday
dreams no idea what he's talking about
[Music]
tree realizes one thing that doesn't add
up in universe be if Carter and Daniel
are a couple then why does Carter take
home tree why does she wake up in the
dorm room in the first place he tells
her that he slept on Ryan's bed and he
only took her home because he was afraid
she was gonna choke on her own vomit
like Janis Joplin this is the same line
at universe a Carter uses in the first
movie when accused of taking advantage
of tree hello
you were wasted last night no I was
afraid you're gonna fall or choke on
your own vomit like Janis Joplin so they
try running the Cissy machine again and
but it doesn't work because the Nerds
don't have the right algorithms the
rattle caused by the machine actually
knocks the clock off the wall indicating
that progress has been halted basically
there's no way for them to test all the
algorithms in one day and when the day
resets they won't know which ones have
already been tested that leaves them
with only one option tree must memorize
each equation and use her reading
Steiner ability or her ability to carry
her memories whenever time is reset to
let them know which algorithms have
already been tested that leads us to a
suicide montage filled with outdated
memes like nyan cat drinking bleach and
even
Isana a couple of trees self kills
contains some fun references like the
poster on the skydiving plane that says
like a leaf
you know because her name is tree and
when she throws herself into the wood
chipper it says tree removal service on
the side of it
you know because her name is tree I love
to think about what happens in all of
these dimensions that tree dies in just
think about it in one of these universes
there's a reality where Carter and his
girlfriend Danielle are just sitting
outside and all of a sudden Danielle's
half-naked best friend falls out of the
sky and splats on the sidewalk in front
of them and they have to deal with that
for the rest of their lives and they
never know why but also during trees
many deaths she discovers that Laurie
actually seems to be the victim in this
world so she spends some of her time
trying to figure out who the killer is
because remember and this one Laurie
isn't evil during one of the suicides
tree jumps from the clock tower and
there's a cool transition to her landing
in Carter's bed to start the loop over
again it was very similar to my favorite
death in the first movie
eventually they figure out the correct
equation and ryan tells tree that she
can choose between closing the loop and
staying in dimension b or closing the
loop behind her as she goes back to
dimension a so she has to make the
decision between her mother and Carter
past her future there's one thing that
you may have missed that I think is the
key to her making that decision when she
has the heart-to-heart talk with her
mother at the motel room she asked her
mom what would you do if you had to
choose between dad and someone else that
you really cared about her mom said
she'd probably choose trees father
because without him she never would have
had tree I'll try to refrain from any
jokes about him having the seed for tree
but I think this is what makes trees
decision to go back to her own dimension
make sense she's not just choosing
Carter over her mom she's choosing all
the possible future memories that she
and Carter might share
let's not forget this line from the
first movie his name's Carter no we do
not have sex but if I finally make it
through this day somehow I'm gonna have
his babies so in order to stop them from
closing the time loop and to reset the
day all in one go she crashes her car
into the power box distribution thing
and decides to give it one more go she
says goodbye to everyone from dimension
B where she learns that Danielle was
actually cheating on Carter with Nick
who if you don't remember it was
Danielle's crush in the first one who
tree made out with at a party that's
fine make it up to me later
why don't what me you know exactly what
you're doing trade we can pause for one
second for my personal opinion even
though I'm not supposed to have one one
thing that kind of bothered me was that
tree never tells Carter B that his
girlfriend is unfaithful she helps out
Laurie she gives advice to everybody
else but she kind of leaves him hanging
so they get everything figured out and
just as they're about to send tree back
home at the Dean bursts in and takes
away their time-travel machine there are
some issues with that but I'll come back
to that later so the gang needs to come
up with a plan to steal the machine back
and they used Danielle who's inspiring
actress in this universe to distract the
Dean while they carry out their plan
meanwhile tree has one more errand to
run in universe B she runs back to the
Med building to save Laurie from the
killer
who she has figured out is dr. Butler
but there's one thing that she didn't
guess his wife is also one of the baby
masked killers in happy deathday dr.
Butler goes behind his wife's back to
sleep with tree but in the new universe
its Laurie which is why the only time
tree was targeted in universe B was once
she tried to protect Laurie also this is
very similar to the original ending that
was cut from the first movie which
Christopher Landon explained in the Q&A
roll X 3 survives the fight and then
wakes up in hospital dr. kind of rushes
everybody out says she needs a rest and
then this nurse comes in and he starts
to put something into trees IV line and
she says oh no no you're not supposed to
be doing that and then the nurse pulls
her mask down and reveals that it's
Gregory's wife and she's basically like
yeah
and then she killed her so it's
interesting to see that ending kind of
found a home in the sequel but there are
some issues with the ending and when
you're dealing with time travel these
things tend to come up at the very
beginning Ryan passes by the trumpet
player in the hall which as I mentioned
is heard every morning on the 18th
however when ryan gets to the dorm room
he sees this unfold which is Tuesday the
19th which is after tree killed Laurie
and got out of the time loop I went back
to the first happy death today to see if
the trumpet is also played on the
morning of the 19th and it's not also
the whole thing with Orion encountering
another version of himself isn't
consistent with anything else that
happens for the rest of the movie for
example when Shree is sent to dimension
B she never encounters tree B and nerds
tell her that the event likely caused
tree B to be sent to another dimension
altogether I also didn't really get what
was the point of introducing a second
Ryan or having Ryan a go through the
time loop at all at the beginning of the
movie because when tree returns to
dimension a at the end it never shows
them solving the second time loop unless
the math that the Nerds used from
dimension B somehow solved all time
loops in all dimensions but that
wouldn't make sense because then some
other Bayfield students and some other
superior dimension could have just
solved everything without tree a ever
having to do anything so by all logical
means when tree a gets back to dimension
a they should still have to solve the
issue of ryan continually resetting to
tuesday the 19th
unless he's saving that for the third
movie but that doesn't seem to be the
case because the mid-credits sequence
suggests that the next movie will
revolve around danielle being tested as
a time loop experiment by the DAR PA
agent Isaac Parker which in itself
doesn't make any sense because they
would run into the same problem that the
Bayfield nerds had in trying to figure
out the correct algorithm to close the
time loop an issue that they were only
able to solve because tree had the
reading Steiner ability and she was able
to somehow remember every single
equation that they tested which by the
way presents a problem of its own
because trees body started to
deteriorate in the first happy deathday
and she only dies 11 times in math and
happy deathday to you it shows her
killing herself about five times I think
it was I mean we'll have to ask a dead
meats but she'd also have to have way
more off-screen deaths in order to
afford her the time to memorize all of
those equations unless she just has a
photographic memory that conveniently
doesn't work when she gets too drunk now
to be fair she did have a similar thing
in the first movie where she was able to
recall everybody on her suspects list
every day but that's considerably less
information than the equation but
anyways back to Danielle the DAR PA
agent was going to use her as a test
subject but they would have no way of
tracking the progress of their
experiments unless danielle remembers
everything from each day and relays the
information to them each time she comes
through something I would have a hard
time believing she would ever agree to
or be capable of but all of that aside
there just seems to be some
inconsistencies with dimension B like
for example there's one morning where
tree wakes up and doesn't interrupt
Carter B and he goes on to asked her if
she remembers his name like he doesn't
the first one but wait they should
already kind of know each other in
dimension dude he's dating Danielle
who's best friends with tree in this
dimension and when Danielle comes up to
the table she acts like it's completely
normal for Carter tree Ryan Samir and
Anna to be hanging out then there's the
fact that the last playthrough of
dimension B ends with Dean Bronson and
the two security guys coming to
confiscate the [ __ ] machine one day
early and while that could just be
explained by the fact that he might have
just noticed the lights on the fritz
again and decided to put an end to it he
specifically says that he told them not
to power it on again which he never did
in dimension B because tree never
reached Tuesday the 19th in that
dimension but the real question we need
to figure out the one thing that could
make or break all of what I just said is
does anyone actually even care besides
me
big thanks to a discovery of witches on
shudder and Sundance now for sponsoring
this video the show follows a modern-day
witch named Diana bishop who
accidentally discovers an ancient text
known as a shmall 782 and when word gets
out about it the entire community of
creatures basically comes after her
including this guy a vampire who not
only wants the book but also has a
craving for her blood she's also quite
interested in him and because she's a
historian and he's been alive
practically forever and experienced
historical events firsthand the series
takes a more realistic approach to
witches vampires and demons and there's
just a ton of twists and turns along the
way I definitely recommend checking it
out plus the soundtrack is a certifiable
bob if you want to watch it you can
catch it exclusively on shudder and
Sundance now just use my promo code for
a 30-day free trial of either service
shudder is the premium streaming service
for fans of the horror and thriller
genre guess what that's you shudder has
the largest and fastest growing human
curated selection of the most thrilling
and dangerous content and Sundance now
has award-winning movies from every
genre including drama comedy true crime
and even including foreign language and
documentary features all streaming
commercial-free it offers an extensive
array of entertainment hand-picked by
acclaimed filmmakers and cultural icons
for a passionate and intellectually
curious audience such as yourselves so
here's what you got it in head over to
discovery of witches tv.com and use the
promo code see Z's world or a free
30-day trial of shudder or some bad smut
and remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ringg
meds at bound for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]